[Música]
el expresidente de honduras juan orlando
hernández fue extraditado a eeuu donde
comparecerá en un tribunal de nueva york
para enfrentar cargos y acusaciones de
participar por décadas en el tráfico de
drogas una acusación federal
estadounidense afirma que durante las
últimas dos décadas hernández participó
en una conspiración corrupta y violenta
de tráfico de drogas para facilitar la
importación de toneladas de cocaína a
eeuu hernández habría recibido millones
de dólares de numerosas organizaciones
del narcotráfico en honduras méxico y
otros países incluso del ex líder del
cártel de sinaloa el chapo guzmán al ex
mandatario se le acusa de utilizar las
ganancias de tráfico de drogas para
enriquecerse financiar a sus campañas
políticas de cometer fraude electoral
incluso en las elecciones presidenciales
de honduras de 2003 y el año 2017 para
analizar lo que ocurrió lo que está
ocurriendo con el ex mandatario quiere
saludar entonces a nuestro primer
invitado el día de joaquín mejía autor
en derechos humanos de derecho
internacional y relaciones
internacionales gracias a joaquín por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
francés de 4 muy buen día le pregunto
por supuesto que significa para la
justicia hondureña esta extradición y si
se puede ver con una medida de ejemplar
y también de escarmiento para políticos
que estén involucrados en el
narcotráfico
muchísimas gracias
buenos días bueno lo primero que hay que
decir es que la tradición de con orlando
hernández representa una medida
agridulce
por un lado digamos que es una victoria
para la justicia de miles de víctimas
porque alguien tan peligroso que ocupó
la primera magistratura del estado
hondureño ha podido ser extraditados a
eeuu con un sistema judicial que es
bastante fuerte en comparación con el
hondureño y que por tanto hay muchas
probabilidades de que se logre justicia
pero al mismo tiempo hay que recordar
que juan orlando hernández sólo
representa la cabeza de la estructura
criminal que utilizó la institución del
estado como el ejército como las fuerzas
armadas el ministerio público el poder
judicial para poder lograr esta
impunidad que ha tenido durante más de
una década para traficar cocaína por
tanto se va juan orlando hernández para
las estructuras criminales con las que
operó siguen intactas en honduras y eso
genera muchísima preocupación y por otro
lado obviamente el mensaje en política
exterior es bastante claro que eeuu
obviamente que tiene no tiene amigos no
tiene aliados porque hay que recordar
que mantuvo y apoyó a juan orlando
hernández y durante todo este tiempo
incluso en el marco del fraude fraude
electoral pero he estado unidos lo único
que tiene es o son intereses y por tanto
cuando ya a alguien como con orlando
hernández no sirve es simplemente es
lanzado en resolver o de la historia y
permite y está ahora terminando por
enfrentar la justicia estadounidense es
que sobre eso quería ahondar joaquín
como eeuu durante tanto tiempo no se dio
cuenta que juan orlando hernández estaba
involucrado en este narcotráfico
estructural en el estado en el estado
hondureño o más bien se hizo la vista
gorda como usted lo decía hasta que le
funcionó y cuando ya no le funcionó pues
ahora venga y paga las consecuencias de
lo que usted hizo por décadas
si así es eeuu siempre ha primado sus
intereses por encima de los intereses de
cualquier sociedad de cualquier pueblo
de cualquier el país y el caso hondureño
es un ejemplo bastante claro y esto
también tiene que ver con la política
exterior que no depende tanto de que
sean demócratas o republicanos
recordemos en el 2009 que es cuando
comienza todo este todo esta conversión
de honduras en un narcoestado récord
vemos que en el año 2009 con el golpe de
estado el gobierno de obama demócrata
fue el único gobierno en el mundo que no
condenó legalmente el golpe de estado y
luego promovió a través de la oea un
diálogo que termino blanqueando los
golpistas y luego en el gobierno de
trump republicano de eeuu fue el
gobierno que no condenó el fraude
electoral y que terminó promoviendo un
diálogo a través de naciones unidas que
blanqueó el fraude electoral y que
permitió que cuando blando hernández se
mantuviera en el poder porque pasa que
eeuu y puso sobre la mesa de juan
orlando hernández dos condiciones uno
que tenía que pacificar el país y por
eso dura se convierte en uno de los
países con mayor represión social a
través del ejército de la policía
militar y de la policía nacional
por otro lado la otra condición era
detener el flujo migratorio y el tráfico
obviamente mientras con orlando
hernández digamos
realizaba todas aquellas cosas que eeuu
decía como por ejemplo el traslado de la
embajada hondureña a jerusalén o como
por ejemplo el tema de convertir a
honduras un tercer país seguro para que
las personas pidiendo asilo en eeuu
tuvieran que regresar a honduras entre
comillas como un país seguro a pesar de
que es uno de los tigres donde andan de
personas por la situación que ha vivido
el país durante todo este tiempo